the guys i hung out with actually wore
me out because they want to go out every
night
they want to party every night we had
drinking yep we had discussions about
alcohol i mean uzbekistan is famous for
its
drinking it's drinking you know it's
that's something to look forward to so i
i do want to travel to that part of the
world when was the last time you were in
that part of the world
early 2000s well then mid-2000s uh 2010s
oh wait so uh by the way we're drinking
vodka what what's the pur yeah i mean
that kind of choice
uzbekistan has incorporated vodka as as
the um the choice um
and that and it informs you know and
it's but but the fascinating thing you
know as a student is what you're
observing as a non-muslim
you know i'm a non-russian i'm this is
all
you know
culturally
new to me and i'm you know a student of
all that right it's a great student
doing my work there so you're like jane
goodall of vodka and russia that's right
just observing that's right yeah and
then you get the you get the summagon
the grass vodka you get you know i have
i've had some long nights on the
kazakhstani frontier yeah that i'm not
proud of um
you know but you got to know the people
and some of them from from yeah but
intellectually so the thing i mean the
the fascinating thing there was it and
just as a
i mean there's a whole yeah i'm
historian right but there there are
great contributions by
you know
and others who who've gone across the
planet and try to understand how muslims
understand their fish in
a different context
so
many uzbeks will say you know
um this is part of our national culture
to drink and eat as we please right and
yet i'm a very devout muslim and so
of course you can encounter other muslim
communities who
won't touch alcohol right
but it's become kind of i think it's
very much um
you know soviet culture left a deep
impression in each of these places and
so
there are ways of thinking
ways of
performing ways of enjoying oneself
that are shared across
soviet and former soviet space to this
day right and you've written also about
muslims in the soviet union that's right
uh
there's an article
that uh there's a paywall so i couldn't
read it and i really wanted to read it
is uh share with you yeah
moscow and the mosque or yeah something
like that right um
by the way just another tangent on a
tangent yeah so i bought all your books
i love them very much
one of the reasons i bought them and
read many parts is uh because they're
easy to buy
unlike articles
every single website has a payoff yeah
yeah so it's it's very hearing i'm sorry
very frustrating to read brilliant
scholars such as yourself no no no um
i wish there was one fee i could pay
everywhere i don't care what that fee is
that's where it gets
allows me to read some of your brilliant
writing no no i think i hear no i think
moving toward
more kind of open source
formatting stuff i think is what a lot
of generals are thinking about now and i
think it's
definitely for the kind of
democratization of knowledge and
scholarship that's definitely an
important thing that we should all think
about and
i think um
you know we need to exert pressure on
these publishers to to do that so i
appreciate this is what i'm doing here
yeah yeah good yeah i appreciate it
you